Він пережив на своїй посаді трьох прем'єрів.
Урядовий рекордсмен Арсен Аваков понад сім років очолював Міністерство внутрішніх справ України
і поляризував українське суспільство: одні його хвалили як ефективного керівника,
а інші - різко критикували і регулярно влаштовували мітинги з вимогами піти у відставку.
Арсен Аваков став міністром внутрішніх справ ще у 2014 році.
Змінювалися очільники уряду, Володимир Зеленський став президентом з обіцянкою "нових облич",
а Аваков залишався і тільки посилював свій вплив, контролюючи Нацполіцію, Нацгвардію, прикордонників, міграційну,
а також Держслужбу з надзвичайних ситуацій.
Він створив у цих структурах своєрідну систему особистих зобов’язань, вважають оглядачі.
І мав не формальний, а реальний контроль над силовиками.
Зеленський називав Авакова "потужним" міністром і досі вважав, що немає кращого кандидата на цю посаду.
За словами експертів, претензій до Авакова у Зеленського чимало, але через кадровий голод у "слуг народу" замінити його не було ким,
та й побоювались це зробити.
Суспільство переконували, що якщо звільнити Авакова, то і так недосконала робота МВС завалиться,
і ситуація зі злочинністю в Україні ще більше погіршиться.
Ці страхи і є одним із секретів виживання Авакова протягом рекордного періоду на посаді, вважають оглядачі.
Загальний рівень злочинності в Україні у 2020-му році знизився на 17 відсотків,
крадіжок поменшало на 30 відсотків, а грабежів - на 33, звітують у Нацполіції.
А найчастішим проступком було порушення маскового режиму.
Коли Арсен Аваков звітував у Верховній Раді минулого року, то запевняв, що рівень розкриття злочинів в Україні - понад 90 відсотків.
А середній показник реєстрації умисних убивств нині майже втричі менший порівняно з 90-ми роками, стверджують у МВС.
Аваков пишається запуском автоматичної системи фотовідеофіксації порушень правил дорожнього руху,
а також сервісами МВС, передусім цифровими документами в рамках спільного з мінцифри проєкту "Дія".
До своїх головних здобутків Аваков приписує реформу Нацполіції і МВС:
мовляв, правоохоронна система стала прозорішою, більш підконтрольною суспільству.
І це проявляється, зокрема, в реакції відомства на тортури і зґвалтування, які вчинили поліцейські в Кагарлику в травні минулого року.
За словами міністра, подібні резонансні події тепер не приховують і їм не потурають.
Кагарлицький відділ поліції повністю розформований. Результати розслідування передали до суду.
Також Аваков запевняв в успішному ході розслідування масової стрілянини у Броварах, що сталася теж у травні минулого року,
коли перевізники перерозподіляли контроль над міжміськими маршрутами.
Нині справа проти 15 осіб за звинуваченням у бандитизмі також передана до суду.
Попри звіти Авакова про успіхи в реформі правоохоронних органів, саме йому активісти закидають провал цієї реформи.
Чимало силовиків, які не пройшли переатестацію, поновилися на посадах й отримали компенсації.
А серед молодих кадрів, які пройшли конкурс на роботу в новій поліції, спостерігалась хвиля масових звільнень розчарованих правоохоронців.
Авакова звинувачували у "злочинній недбалості" деяких працівників.
Зокрема, під час трагічних подій у Княжичах у грудні 2016-го, коли внаслідок перестрілки між поліцією охорони
та спецпідрозділом КОРД загинули п'ятеро правоохоронців.
Усю країну також шокувало вбивство п'ятирічного хлопчика у Переяславі-Хмельницькому, коли двоє п'яних поліцейських стріляли по банках.
Українці все ще нагадують міністру і про корупційний скандал з так званими "рюкзаками Авакова".
Його син Олександр фігурував у справі про розтрату державних коштів під час закупівлі рюкзаків для Нацгвардії України.
Їхня вартість була завищеною, а якість не відповідала стандартам. Зрештою справу закрили.
Найбільше ж критики на адресу Авакова - за бездіяльність і неналежне розслідування резонансних вбивств і нападів на журналістів та активістів.
Це, зокрема, справи Катерини Гандзюк, Ірини Ноздровської, Павла Шеремета.
Розслідування вбивства журналіста білоруського походження викликає особливе обурення у суспільстві.
Правоохоронці назвали імена підозрюваних, але багато хто вважає обвинувачення проти них сфабрикованими,
а докази непереконливими, що спричинило хвилю протестів.
Ця справа найбільше б'є по репутації Авакова. За три роки після гучних заяв міністра слідство не показало реальних результатів.
Наразі справа знаходиться у суді і до завершення процесу ще далеко.
За словами Зеленського, відповідальність за цю справу несе особисто Аваков і має довести її до кінця.
Утім, сам міністр, подаючи у відставку, схоже, прагне позбутися такої відповідальності.